mio padre era un agricoltore figlio di
agricoltori di generazione in
generazione
mia madre figlia di allevatori di vacche
e pecore da questi due genitori doveva
nascere un altro agricoltore o
quantomeno un allevatore ma andando in
campagna non mi piacevano gli odori non
mi piacevano le asprezze le acidità che
provenivano dai terreni concimati
comitato d'ammonio il fosfato
e poi i campi di grano diserbati con il
glifosate o altre molecole chimiche e
quindi decisi di iscrivermi in lingue e
letterature straniere perché volevo
andarmene via dalla campania e dalla
sicilia
la malattia di mio padre mi tenne legato
però alla terra
e allora dovetti cercare di capire
perché avvertivo quegli odori
nauseabondi in campagna cominciai a fare
una ricerca e vidi che la storia che
stavo vivendo io era la storia che aveva
vissuto qualcuno agli inizi del
novecento una guerra mondiale che
durante quella guerra mondiale ci fu un
uomo che risolvete un problema alla
germania per riuscire a fare gli
esplosivi fritz haber riuscì a
sintetizzare a costruire un sistema per
sintetizzare limitato dal moio che serve
per fare gli esplosivi risultato da
moglie viene utilizzato oggi in tutte le
aziende agricole per dare energia alle
piante ma sempre il solito amico fritz
riuscì a anche inventare una formula del
gas mostarda chiamato iprite perché
venne utilizzato per la prima volta
durante la prima guerra mondiale per
testarlo
a di in belgio in una notte ci furono
100 mila morti
questa ibride venne poi evoluta perché
si dovevano gasare uccidere sterminare
circa 6 milioni di persone nei campi di
sterminio
e allora venne fatto lo zigon a che
venne voluto in sì come sempre
utilizzando la formula delle prime come
base e riuscirono a eliminare una buona
parte della nostra umanità che vive sul
pianeta ma questo zico beh servì anche
da base per riuscire a formulare la
gente arancio che ben utilizzato in
vietnam per the fall year e le foreste
che servivano a far nascondere i get con
che difendevano le loro risate si chiama
agente arancio perché dopo dopo esser
passato con sul sulle foglie le foglie
diventano rosse arancioni e cadono e
quindi queste sono le raccomandazioni
per fare agricoltura oggi visto questo
era logico per me scappare da un posto
altamente inquinato però un giorno mi
ritrovai davanti come davanti a una
porta però era murata dietro sapevo che
c'era la storia di un antico magazzino
di frumento eros colpito anche nella
pietra chiave di questo magazzino una
spiga detto c'è qualcosa che devo
riuscire a farmi dare dal passato e
allora andai in un vecchio villaggio
medievale a aveva ancora ci sono gli
abitanti a montalbano elicona dove
un'anziana signora ci racconta che
l'idea vicino al bosco di malabotta c'è
un posto che chi ha richiamato argi
musco dove c'erano i giganti e gli dei
non potete comprendere la gioia dei miei
bambini quando sentiremo parlare che
l'avvicinò c'erano stati giganti allora
andammo lì a cercare le opere dei
giganti e su un'altura chiama tarditi
musco dove c'è l'orante e il profilo di
una donna che sta pregando
dove vengono anche dall'india per
meditare e vengono raffigurati una delle
figure di profili di dove e ceo dice che
i titani kronos e rea generano leghisti
e demetra demetra la dea del grano
farina dell'agricoltura allora capì che
c'era qualcosa che di strano è vero che
in quel posto vissero dagli esseri
particolari i terrestre però per
riuscire ad attingere alla storia e
anche alla a quello che al pensiero a
trovare un collegamento tra quello che
faceva loro mi servivano dei codici mi
servivano delle chiavi per aprire quella
porta murata e allora le trovai qui i
codici alla stazione sperimentale di
granicoltura di caltagirone ente storico
del 1927 dove sono tutti i 50 frumenti
locali antichi siciliani 45 duri cinque
teneri che erano lì pronti aspettavano
qualcuno che li cominciasse a riprodurre
a moltiplicare ea spargere sulla terra
sul territorio della nostra bellissima
isola e allora iniziamo da pochi grammi
e cominciamo a seminarli a fare delle
parcelle questo è un lavoro che fa già
la stazione ma noi cominciamo a
seminarne sempre di più sempre di più
questa è la zona da dove poi questi se
vi vengono prelevati e sparsi nell'arco
di tre anni da pochi ettari siamo
arrivati a 700 ettari in sicilia
produciamo migliaia di tonnellate di
frumento mai mutato geneticamente che ha
un glutine assolutamente diverso era
quello che ci avevano tolto dalla tavola
propinandoci il nostro glutine allora
bisognava cercare i codici il frumento è
un codice che ha attivato la nostra
civiltà e quindi era giusto recuperarlo
per riuscire a digitare al giusto codici
affinché non ci venga ritirato più il
bancomat o la nostra carta di credito ma
dobbiamo farci dare all'energia giusto e
dc tanto il codice giusto e questi grani
quindi da qui si parte con un'opera di
comunicare ai bambini per evitare che si
perda la memoria perché nel momento in
cui noi parliamo la memoria
la conoscenza che perdiamo la nostra
occasione di evoluzione e per recuperare
la memoria bisogna rifare ripristinare
le azioni fatte tanti e tanti anni fa ma
non per un ritorno al passato ma è per
fare un memoriale dove riuscire a far
rivivere delle azioni che provocano un
altra energia smuovono altre onde senti
altri rumori e vedere paesaggi di grani
antichi collega tv in fondo c al
castello di pietratagliata e far sì che
il sacco però bene il grano antico con
un castello medievale s'accoppia bene e
quindi riuscire anche a ri riottenere un
paesaggio diverso
mario produce cibo giuseppe alla
conoscenza queste sono persone che
stanno ai margini
e però hanno loro le soluzioni e poi
incontrando ceccarelli uno scienziato
italiano che vive in india la diversità
la diversità dove noi non cerchiamo più
l'uniformità lo standard l'omogeneità
all'interno di un campo di grano ma
abbiamo delle miscele di di tantissime
varietà per attivare la variabilità la
diversità all'interno di un campo di
grano dove una spiga non è uguale
all'altra ma sono tutte spighe una
diversa dall'altra la più bassa sostiene
la più alta in caso di vento la più alta
difende la più bassa in caso di
infestanti
ecco la diversità che non è un errore
come nei campi di grano moderno non è
terrore non è orrore la diversità ma la
diversità è ricchezza e occasione di
cambiamento ma è l'unica occasione per
poterti agganciare alle evoluzioni come
in questo periodo i cambiamenti
climatici
il clima sta cambiando il tempi stanno
cambiando dobbiamo essere capaci di
evolverci ma è più elementi diversi
abbiamo dentro di noi accanto a noi
attorno a noi più occasioni noi abbiamo
di poter
evitare di morire e quindi in natura non
è l'essere più forte che vince ma è
l'essere che ha più capacità di
adattamento
poi anche la fao ha detto sai sei un
caso studio su come poter studiare ma
che significa no no no stai facendo le
cose buone
va bene non sei un caso particolare di
wood questo anche ad altri contadini
altri agricoltori in sicilia perché è
giusto essere anche in tanti ma
cerchiamo la collaborazione anche
all'esterno non solamente nella campagna
la vogliamo nella città nelle strade nei
negozi nelle vostre menti affinché nelle
vostre menti si formi un concetto di
qualità del cibo che il vostro cibo la
vostra energia per riuscire a sostenere
la vostra vita la vostra famiglia e
quella della società in cui noi viviamo
tutti quanti un bambino sta cercando di
spostare un pallone di 350 chili ci è
riuscito per pochi centimetri
faccio un appello a tutti quanti venite
dateci una mano d'aiuto perché nei campi
di grano della nostra società
bisogna togliere un sacco di balle che
sono state disseminate in questi ultimi
60 anni